feature toggles can improve the workflow
of your development team and lead to
quicker software delivery frederick
osberg from unleash will show you how
feature toggles can help you
alright
so i brought with me a friend of mine
here today to help to introduce you to
feature toggles
he is a brilliant engineer and he's the
creator of unleash which is the largest
open source solution for feature
flagging on github
and i'm really excited to have him here
today to help explain
future toggles
so welcome evar and thank you for being
here
thanks for having me
yeah it's my pleasure i was curious just
to kick this off um i've been in the
future toggle game for quite some time
now
and i just wonder
what prompted you to start feature
toggling and what was kind of the
trigger to
make this happen and create this uh
this system
yeah thanks for asking that uh actually
i i started on on the leash or exploring
feature toggling concept back in
2014 and
and my kind of my goal or the mission or
the reason for starting with that is
that i i deeply care about developer
efficiency and and i was working as a
tech lead and a team back then and
and we had already kind of automated how
we release software to an environment to
all our environments so we had kind of
the deployment pipeline all set up and
we could in theory
release whenever we wanted
and in our team we had also decided to
do vehicle sprints because we wanted to
kind of have this extreme focus and
cheap features all the time uh because
it makes sense and and and also
we wanted to kind of learn all all the
time but i saw that we often failed to
do releases every week we couldn't kind
of ship software every week and and they
it bugged me a lot because we ended up
with all these
feature branches long running feature
branches um
and it actually was quite hard to manage
these feature branches because uh there
was a lot of changes and and it was kind
of
you know when you're working on a larger
feature it takes some time to write that
code and get it right and test it a bit
and get some feedback on it yeah
and it feels like uh when you're pushing
something to production it needs to be
like perfect because
you're actually kind of presenting it to
real users out there
and and for me this bugged me a lot
because they ended up us holding
different feature branches back in kind
of separate kind of local branches or
test environments and stuff like that
but they will never merge and we kind of
postponed a lot of the learning
right and
and for me this uh this was a nightmare
and i felt like my it was kind of
cognitive overload and i thought that
there has to be better ways we we should
we should try to
to ship some code all the time in
smaller chunks but uh but hide them from
the users instead and this was when i
started learning more about trunk based
development and there were certain
techniques to kind of succeed with
trunk-based development
and one of the techniques that a lot of
people talked about was feature toggles
or or feature flags and
i really love the idea and and
and at this time there was a couple of
other open source solutions for this as
well
but usually they were kind of tied to a
specific framework or they were kind of
very static that it was just a file in
your app and you could kind of change
the toggle but there was
less of a
dynamic built into it that i really
wanted
and
and this is why i started looking into
creating something like english i i
really wanted something that could allow
me to do trunk based development divider
features into smaller chunks even though
the complete feature was not releasable
to end user i still wanted to have the
ability
to ship the code to production just to
get some learnings like does it really
make sense does it work with production
data is the firewall open all of that
kind of things that we developer care
about but also that then i could know
that a small portion of the feature is
done and i can start think of the next
small portion of the feature instead of
thinking about everything
all the time
so just curious for the people that
don't know what is trunk based
development
so trunk based development is is a
very popular technique these days it's
kind of opposite to more like a git flow
where you use branches for everything so
the idea is that you mainly work on the
trunk or the master branch or the main
branch you try to kind of all the time
commit directly to that
that trunk
branch
is so that you're never kind of having a
long-running feature branches in
parallel this means that you you have
all your developers in the team
collaborating on the same code base
instead of having local copies of the
code base in different states
right
isn't that dangerous though couldn't you
like easily get something into the
master branch that
isn't
completely tested or doesn't work
100 yet or
yes exactly and this is why you need
feature toggles because then you use a
feature toggle to wrap that code so that
you make sure that it's not exposed
before the code is ready to be exposed
right
so tell me a little bit more about that
because uh just curious to know how that
works actually
yeah so so the the kind of the
a feature toggles is a actually a very
simple technique when you think about it
it's just kind of a small if statement
that you've wrapped the new code in
and only if that feature toggle kind of
evaluates the true we should evaluate
the new code if not we should use the
old code so basically you can think of
it like you're you're replacing the the
the branches in your repository
with branches in your code instead
and this
adds a lot of benefits so it means that
when you're using a tool like unleash
you can start dynamically changing who
gets access to a feature based on
certain criterias
in a running application in production
so you don't have to kind of redeploy or
anything like that
interesting
and and this allows you to test early in
production you can verify the new thing
you're working on even though it's not
completely finished yet you can test it
on yourself and only enable it for your
user in a production environment test it
with real data make sure that the little
part that you already built actually
works the way you intended to work
right so you have something that's not
completely finished and you hide it
behind the flag so that it's not turned
on
before you're actually ready to turn it
on but you're continuously putting that
into the master branch so that you don't
end up having multiple different states
uh that could clash in the future
exactly and and and working like this
allows the team to really collaborate on
the code base uh it means that everyone
will see your changes very fast because
it's safe to kind of just commit
directly to the trunk uh and and have
that directly in and shared between the
developers it means that you can
basically refactor your code any time
because there will not be kind of
some new feature on a different feature
branch that is not yet complete that you
have to wait for before you can do this
huge refactorization
so so there is a ton of benefit of
working this way
amazing is what about drawbacks like
nothing is completely 100 perfect so
just curious are there any drawbacks to
using future toggles
yes of course uh and and
if you think about like a feature toggle
is it's kind of technical depth by
nature because you are having different
version often of a feature or the code
itself you have two implementations of
something in your code base so obviously
you would not
want to have that for a very long time
but it really makes sense when you are
kind of trying out new ideas or working
on a new feature
or
something like that it really makes
sense to kind of encapsulate that in a
feature toggle but we should also be a
bit careful because if you're just
adding feature toggles but never taking
them away allowing multiple code pads to
coexist in the code base
that can be actually quite dangerous
down the road because
uh usually developers switch team that
might
equate from your company and it could be
kind of like uh
down the road you can end up in a
situation where you have a lot of
feature toggles
but you're not sure if you can turn them
off anymore will that work will your
application still work
so you kind of really depend on a
certain state of that toggle and when
you come to that situation it's really
about time to start cleaning up that and
remove the dead code and make sure that
you only kind of execute the code that
you really want to execute
and and there is other things there's as
well and that is it will
having a lot of features will also make
your code a bit harder to test actually
because
you will need to kind of
you will have a lot of different parts
through your application
give based on what
what the state of the feature toggle
will be if it's on or off or maybe it's
a certain variant so it might not just
be on but it could be divided between
different implementations
and then you certainly come in a state
should you test all the permutation of
all the toggles in your application
maybe not but you should at least try to
test the the
uh the important ones at least with kind
of automated tests and and make sure
that what most of your user will i will
end up seeing in production should
obviously be a tested cobalt and then
there is a discussion if you are also
need to test all the different
feature toggle states
maybe maybe not it depends a bit on
which type of application you're working
on i guess right
so i'm actually a bit curious about this
because
when we're talking about deploying
multiple times a day or
or getting to a point where we're
releasing all the time then obviously a
big part of that is having automated
tests so you know that the code that you
release is actually
working and functional
when you push it out to production
but when you're relying on a third-party
program and i know that a lot of the
feature talking solutions that exist
today
are like traditional sas platforms uh
you set up your feature toggles there
and and you kind of use them in your
code and you have to communicate with
them so you kind of have this external
dependency
and as you mentioned that could be
really hard to test so
how can you get around that how can you
make sure that you can test your code
thoroughly
even when you have a third party
that you have to rely on
yeah and that's actually one of the
benefit of choosing an open source
platform such as unleash because you can
you you can actually just take the
unleash open source and and that would
be 100 protocol compliant with the sdk
uh the enterprise will obviously give
you some more features but you can take
that and run this as part of your
integration testing if you really want
to test the interaction with unleash and
then you can just kind of pre-configure
that open source
instance to be in a certain state so
that you can kind of test all the states
that are important to you
uh a lot of our sdks also allow you to
do
uh testing for instance the java sdk has
a built in kind of fake unleash
implementation where you can kind of set
the toggles in certain states but that's
typically more useful in more like unit
test cases where you kind of are
building unit tests for a small portion
of the code
but usually that doesn't make sense when
you start integration testing or
end-to-end testing then you often want
to actually have some kind of
instance running that is replicating
what you're doing
and that's
quite easy to achieve with unleash i
would say
interesting
anything more you feel like uh it's
important to talk about when we're
we're talking about yeah i think
i think there is a lot of things and i'm
sure that you will cover a lot of the
important topics in in this course i'm
super happy that you are doing this
course i think uh in the end there is
obviously drawbacks with everything
there is nothing that comes for free but
as long as we kind of handle those
drawbacks and and take care of the
techno data make sure that we have some
processes to also clean up that we set
aside maybe a day a month or something
to kind of validate the toggles we are
using are they still relevant i think
the the benefits kind of outweighs the
drawbacks and and i see that
teams starting to adopt feature talks or
wanting to run with the trunk best
development process
uh seems to gain a lot of value out of
using feature toggles and
to me it's kind of an eye opener has
seen in in in real life how it's
accelerated the learnings from the
software we're working on and and how we
can safely release all the time
uh in small chunks
get feedback on those changes are they
working are they doing what we intend
them to do
and kind of bit by bit building out
complex features which is uh
is an awesome capability to have to be
honest
yeah it's uh
sounds amazing so
i'm really excited uh that you're here
and we're able to give us this kind of
introduction to feature toggling so i
want to thank you for taking time to do
that
and
now hopefully we're going to be ready to
dive into
the code and start implementing that on
our own which is going to be exciting
thanks for having me
you're welcome
all right
so we heard a little bit about what
feature totals are and how you can use
them
so now we're going to get into it a
little bit more
and
i want to stress that
in the most basic form
a feature toggle is just an if else
statement
so what you could do is you could have a
flag in your code
that says whether or not something is on
or off and
obviously if you're diligent and you're
able to remember to turn this flag on
and off when you're developing or you're
loading it from some kind of
configuration file
that can be enough to just get the ball
rolling and get started because it means
that you can go ahead and merge in your
code at any point in time
so what we'll do is we'll take a look at
how we can perform this and how we can
implement it into the free code camp
code base
so let's get to it
alright so here we have the free
codecamp website
and it's running locally on my machine
so let's just take a quick moment and go
through what's here
as you can see we're at the landing page
right now and we have this text in the
middle
and the call to action that says get
started it's free
and if we scroll down
we have an as seen in section
we have an alumni section
and in the end here we have the
certification section
so
that's basically the
structure of the landing page
now
let's go to the top and we're just going
to focus on this part right here
and what we want to do is we want to
take this section right here
and we're going to swap it out with a
new section
so we'll take a look at the code we'll
take a look at the new section
and then we'll take a look at how we can
use a flag to toggle this on or off
so here we are inside of the free code
camp code base
and we're inside of index.js
now the landing top component here is
the existing component that corresponds
to what we just saw
on the main page
and we have this landing top v2 here
which is the new design that we want to
go ahead and implement
so what we'll do is we'll uncomment this
and we'll scroll down a little bit
and we have a piece of code here that
we're also gonna
comment in
and then we'll comment this out
just so we can see
the changes that we made
if we head back to the
and now we can see that we have the new
component in place of the old one
we still have one issue though and we
have the header up here that is a
universal header
but we chose to include it in the new
design uh in the
this component so what we'll go ahead
and do is we'll go back to the code
we'll find the header components
and
we'll take the universal nav and for now
we'll just
go ahead and comment that out
and
if we head back to the browser now we
should see it update
and
here we have the
new landing page
so what we'll look at now
is
hiding this behind a flag so that we can
easily toggle it on or off
let's head back to the code
and the first thing we'll do is we'll go
ahead and create a new file in source
called flags
yes
and in here we'll create a constant
called new design
on
and we'll set it initially to be false
now what we'll do is we'll go back to
our landing page
and we'll change this because it's not
good to have
a bunch of uncommented code around and
we want this to be flexible we need to
find a way to be able to display either
this component
or this component based on the flag
so
let's
go ahead and import the new design on
flag
and i got some help there for my auto
importer
so now we have the new design on
imported
and we'll use this
to
conditionally render one thing or the
other so we'll say cost landing page
component
or landing top component be precise
and we'll say new design
on
and if it's on
we want to render
this part right here
otherwise
and we'll denote that with a colon
we want
the old landing page component
and now we'll put it in
right here
so basically we're saying if it's on
giving me this part if it's off
give me this part
and then we're taking the
value there
and we're rendering
it inside the main container
let's go ahead and see what we get now
in the browser if we head back
now we have the old
landing page but we're still lacking the
universal navigation so let's go ahead
and fix that as well
so we'll go into index tsx in the header
and we'll comment this back
and we'll do the same thing here so
we'll say new design on
and we'll use that
to render the
universal nav
so
navigation equals new design on then we
want nothing
otherwise
we want the universal navigation
so remember that the new design has the
navigation built in so we don't want
anything in that case
if it's not on
then we want to render it because it
belongs with the old components
so if we hit save on that and go back to
the code or the browser
we now have the navigation back as well
so
what this allows us to do
is we can go back to the code
and we can go to our flag
and we can flip this to true
and now we have one central
state
that controls
whether or not we show
one component or the other
now we're soon getting to the really
cool part
and
the ultimate goal that we're trying to
achieve here is that we want to be able
to
quickly
merge things back into the master branch
and get things into production without
having to worry about whether or not
it's 100 functional
because we can make the improvements as
we go along
and
hide the feature from the user base
until it's 100 complete
now
what we have now
a flag that we can flip
on or off in our code
it's going to work but it's a little bit
brittle
you know
if you have
a flag that you have to have a conscious
relationship with and you have to know
whether or not it's on or off when you
push your code
it adds mental overhead and it just it's
it's one more thing to keep track of
and what could be really dangerous if
you actually forget that you turn it on
on something that's not finished and you
inadvertently could push out something
that's unfinished
to your customers or users of your hobby
project or
whatever it is that you have running in
production
so we need to do something to make sure
that that can happen so
we'll jump back to the code
and we'll take a look at how we can make
this flag
a little bit more
dynamic
so right now it's set to true
and
what i want to do is i want to use the
process env
node environment and i actually want to
say that if it is in development
then
i want new design to be on
and if i hit save on that
we should be able to see the new design
still because we are in development we
are running the node process here in
development it's not in production
so let's go ahead and verify that and
say that if
we want the new design to be on in
production
we have to be running process in
production
and now you can see we get the old
design or the
current design
so that's going to
help us
because that means that when we actually
deploy this if we have this set to
development we don't have to worry about
this making it into production
[Applause]
provided that we are specifying the
correct
parameters when we are
running the process
all right so one of the pitfalls and we
kind of mentioned it when we're doing
the
environment variable is that
if you're just having a flag in your
code it can be quite easy to
risk
not remembering to
turn it back off again like you're
working on a feature something's
happening maybe the babies are crying or
you're burning your food or you have to
run your minds elsewhere and you come
back and you forget that you put the
flag on and you commit something and
maybe
uh
you
maybe you get it into production like oh
obviously you'll have some other guards
right you're a good developer you have
people reviewing your code and someone's
going to catch it i'm sure
but what if they don't like
it can happen [ __ ] happens and
you
do have run this risk if you're not
using environment variables and you have
the flag in your code but
there are easy ways to get around that
now
another thing that you might experience
is that
you actually
reduce the benefits of feature toggling
when you're putting it in the code
because one of the big benefits
is that you can actually
use the configuration
from an external location
to toggle the feature on and off in your
code without actually doing another
deploy
and like that's the real magic not the
stuff that you can actually merge it in
that's good that's nice but
the real magic happens when you can
actually control your application
from an external source and you don't
have to do a new deploy in order to
in order to get a new version of your
code out there you can just flip a
switch and there's another version of
your code that will run live in
production
so think about that like you have a
product manager or something that is
launching a new feature and it's at home
and it's friday night
and you're trying to launch a new
feature because you always launch on
fridays right that's that's a golden
rule
but
what if something goes wrong like
he has to call up his developers they
have to figure out what went wrong
and
then they have to deploy a new version
well what if he could just
push a button
and go on with this weekend and then on
monday
we can go back to trying to figure out
what's wrong
that's a real magic
and that's what we're gonna take a look
at in the next section
all right
so what we'll do now is we'll focus on
taking this flag that we have inside of
our code and we want to move it to an
external service so that we can toggle
the feature on or off
without having to redeploy our code
now the way we'll do that is we'll use a
service called json bin which allows you
to host json in the cloud and you get an
api url that you can use to retrieve the
json configuration
so let's go ahead and create our json
configuration and we have the bin
creation screen in front of us right
here so
we'll go ahead and put in
a json configuration here
and we'll start with the open curly
brackets
and a key that says new design
and we want the default value to be
false for now
also we have to make sure
that we flip this from a private to a
public bin so that we are able to get
the configuration without an api key
just for testing purposes of course
if you're running this in production or
you want a more robust setup obviously
you want to have a proxy in between
that can take care of hiding your api
key on the server side
but for now we're going to keep it
public so that we can easily
retrieve the information and then we'll
take a look at how to use a proxy later
on
so let's go ahead and hit create on that
and you can see now we have a access url
down here in the bottom of the screen
we'll copy that
and just make sure that this is working
paste it in
and here you can see we have the json
configuration
all right so now that we have that we
can jump into the code and start
putting together the pieces that we need
in order to retrieve the configuration
all right so here we are back in the
code and we are in a
component called default layout which is
a
component that wraps all of the other
components in this project
and this is where we'll add the logic
for retrieving the configuration and it
will use it to supply the configuration
down to the components that need it
now this is something i would normally
use hooks for
but since we are using class components
here this is the method that we are
going to work with so
to begin with
let's go ahead and add a constructor
and we'll go ahead and take some props
and we'll say
super
props
and then we'll initialize our state
and we want the state to have a ready
property
and we're going to add a new design
pulse
that's going to be our initial state
now
next up we'll add a fetch
feature toggle configuration
and inside of here we are going to
get the configuration from our json bin
so let's go ahead and say fetch
and now we need to go ahead and
retrieve the url so we'll go ahead and
copy that
and we'll paste that in here and then
we'll say
we'll get the result and if the result
is okay so if it's
200
then we want to
return
press json
and then we'll take that json data
and we'll say if
date
ready
is false
and we'll say this set state
ready is true
and new design equals json.new design
otherwise we'll say this set states
and we make sure we put this in the
right place
and we want to return here
so
if ready is not
false we will just want to put the
new design
to the json new design value
let's go ahead and hit save on that
and then we
need to add this here on the state
because we're referring to the class
and
let's go ahead and throw an error here
if we fail to
get the configuration and we'll just
catch
and log it out for now
all right so let's go ahead and make
sure that we call this function
and we'll go ahead and do that in the
component bitmaps so we'll say this
patch feature toggle configuration
and then i think we set the new design
to be false in the json bin let's just
check that quickly
we did
so we'll flip this to true just to see
that we are getting the expected results
when we
retrieve our configuration we can also
inspect the network request
um
so
let's go ahead and just log out the
state
in our render function
and then we'll head over to the browser
and we'll check out the behavior
all right so let's go ahead and open up
our developer tools
and we can see that in our console we
have two objects the first one is the
first state so
we set new design to true and ready to
false in the initial state
and then we have the
updated state here
where new design is false and red is
true so we get new design from the json
bin
and we set the property to be
false
we can also verify this by checking the
network tab
so let's hit refresh here
and that's gonna
capture all of the network requests
and we can see
in the top here that we have the
request
it's asking towards
this url
and the response is the
json bin content all right
so now that we have that let's focus on
getting this data into the components
that need it
we'll head back to the code
and now we need to pass this state
down to
the header
because we need to hide the universal
navigation based on the flag
and then we also need to get it into the
landing page component
so let's take a look at this render
function here
and
we can
see
that we have a lot of links
you can see we have the header here
let's go ahead and pass
new design
here
and say this state new design
and then we are going to
have to do a little bit more work in
order to get it into the
landing page component because we are
rendering children here
which is basically the react way of
saying that anything that is
put inside of this component when it's
rendered
all of its children
are going to be fit inside of here so we
can't access the children at the time
they are initialized which means that we
can't actually pass the children props
or properties so what we need to do is
we need to go ahead and
recreate the children
we'll do react
children
map
and then we'll pass the children as the
first argument
and the second argument will be a
function
and we will receive the first
or the child's
as the first
argument
and inside of this function we want to
take the child
and we want to clone it and
decorate it with the new parameters that
we want to pass down so let's do
react
clone element
and make sure we put return in front of
that
and we'll say child
and we'll say new design
this state
new design
all right
so that should take all of the children
loop over him
and take each child make a clone
and pass it these properties or this
property
so let's go ahead and
find the index
page component
i will do index page
now let's go in here in the index.tsx
file
of the index page
and that's going to be the child
that we're passing the prop to so
we need to accept props here and since
this is a tsx file we're going to be
good citizens and create an interface
and we'll say
new design
is a boolean
and let's say page is a string
and let's go ahead and
ask the props here
and then we'll take the properties which
is an object
and we'll
pass them along to the landing page here
let's open up that component
and
we'll accept
the parameter here
let's go ahead and log this out
so now if we head over to the browser
and we open up the developer tools we
should be able to see
a console log that says false and we do
right down here so that means that we've
successfully
moved the
data down to the landing page component
so let's go ahead and go back to our
code
and we'll swap out
the
new design on here
with the new design property
up here so we'll do this instead of our
built-in flag
and we are going to go ahead and do the
same in the header component
let's go ahead and find that which is up
here
and
we are going to say
instead of new design on we'll say this
new design
and currently
this is set to pull so we expect our
old landing page to return which it does
and here we also have the header with
just a little bit slow rendering there
all right
so to round off this section we want to
make sure that we can use the jsbin
configuration
to control
which design is running on this site
and in order to do that we need to make
a few final changes to the code so let's
go ahead and jump back in
and you can see we already have built
the functionality to fetch the
configuration and to update the state
and now we need to make sure that we're
able to
get the new configuration once the
configuration changes in the js bin
and the way we'll handle that is we're
going to send up an interval
and that interval is going to refetch
the configuration
every five seconds
so we'll go ahead and set
an interval here
and
the function that's going to run is this
fetch feature toggle configuration
and as we said we want that to run every
five seconds
so with that in place
now we just need to go down here and we
need to make it change to this url
because
we want the latest configuration every
time we fetch against this
otherwise we would get the
first version
and not the updated ones so we need to
make sure that we put on latest at the
end here
and since we set up an interval here we
also want to make sure that we go ahead
and clear that interval
should the component
amount
if we hit save on that we can head back
to the browser
and as you can see we still have the
original view here
but if we head over to our js bin
and we hit edit
and we flip this state to true
and we go ahead and update the bin
now if we head back to our website
we have the new design
in place because we're now controlling
the feature using the
js bin
configuration
and there you have it
and honestly this is easily one of my
favorite things about feature toggling
having the ability to just flip a flag
like this
and then
seeing the changes
instantly reflected
in your website running in production
i mean that's incredible
having the ability to
release code with the confidence that if
anything goes wrong
you can just turn it off
that's incredible it gives you so much
safety
and it makes you so much more efficient
as a developer
of course you'll still write tests
you'll still take the precautions that
you need to take
but
just having that safety net just having
that level of certainty that if
something goes wrong you can just turn
it off
makes it a joy
to write and release code because
you're eliminating the element of
risk and honestly
that's like magic to me
all right
so
let's talk about some of the drawbacks
of using this method of implementation
so earlier we talked about the fact that
if you're using built-in
feature flags into your code you miss
out on some of the benefits of using
feature toggles
now you can get some of those back by
using an external configuration
but if you do it like we did now
you have to be extremely careful because
when you're working with raw jason
and that's controlling your application
it can be a little bit brittle because
json is a data format and you need to
adhere 100
to the format
in order for it to work
so there is a very little margin for
error
now
in json bin
luckily we have some protection so we
can't just put in any arbitrary value
and hit update because it will say that
it's invalid json and we won't be
allowed to update
but what we can do is we can put in
something like this where we put in
a string which is
valid json
but we put in the string false
so maybe we were doing something quickly
maybe we didn't realize that you have to
use true or false without quotes for it
to be a boolean
but the result now is that we still have
the
design
that we started with so we didn't
actually make the update that we wanted
to we have to go back here
and we have to change this now
to
say pauls
and then hit the update button again
and now we get a result that we expected
so you can see that you have to be very
precise
in your instructions and it's not
something that you would
let someone that's non-technical there
so you would have to kind of keep this
in
the developer family
um which could be fine but you need to
make sure that you are being vigilant uh
when you're
working with this stuff
so
that's one thing
another thing might be that as cool as
this functionality that we've
implemented is
and as powerful as it is it's still a
little bit limiting
see you might want to give certain users
access to the feature in production
maybe you want to do a gradual rollout
that rolls out to percentage of your
users maybe you want to have some
metrics on who are getting access to
this feature or not
or maybe you just want to
be able to connect from different
applications maybe you have more than
one application and they're in different
programming languages and you have to
write these bindings for each
application and that's when you
kind of
start looking for and vendor of these
things because
now we're talking about hours of
investing into developing something
homegrown
and there might be better or
more robust alternatives out there that
you can use for free
and that's what we're gonna to look into
in the next section we'll look at some
paid actors we'll look at some free
actors
and then we'll dive into the product
that i'm working on which is called
unleash
right so when you'd want to do more than
just basic feature toggling uh like
rolling out to a percentage of your
users
having certain users get access in
production
um
getting metrics
connecting multiple applications
you quickly find yourself wanting to
look for a vendor
and
i firmly believe
that looking for a vendor in this kind
of situation is a good idea because
every line of code that you write
yourself you're going to have to
maintain and code isn't now
in my mind is a living product it lives
over time you're going to have to have a
conscious relationship to it it's not
like you write it once and then you're
done you're going to find
that you have to work with this code
again and again and again and you have
to either add capabilities that weren't
there before or you're going to have to
fix something that isn't working as
intended
so with that said let's take a look at
some of the vendors that you can use for
feature totally
and there are a number of actors in the
space that you can utilize
and i'm not going to go into detail on
them here but i will mention them so you
can make up your own mind
so you have platforms like launch darkly
split i o w
uh vwo cloudbees optimizely and harness
which basically they operate as
traditional sas platforms
and then you have some open source
alternatives such as git lab
rollout clipper
and unleash
which is the solution that i'm working
on
now which solution should you choose
well i'm not going to tell you that and
first of all because i'm severely biased
and obviously i want you to use unleash
but
secondly it really depends on your needs
the vendors mentioned here all have
their strengths and weaknesses and they
all have their
unique development philosophy
and i will say this though
when you're choosing a vendor i think
it's also important to take a look at
the development philosophy and make sure
that it matches your own
so with that said i'm going to tell you
a few words about the development
philosophy at unleash
so first and foremost we are huge fans
of open source unleash started as an
open source product and it still is one
today
and 95 of our code is freely available
on github
and if that serves your use case you can
use that for free
no problem
and what's great about open source is
that if you have a problem that we can
easily fix you can submit a issue
and if we tell you that
we can't fix the issue because we have
other priorities you can always submit a
pull request and fix it yourself
or you could fork the code and make your
own adjustments as you see fit
and
in today's development climate we
believe that this flexibility is a key
factor in order to succeed
in
bringing tools to developers
developers are curious beings we like to
see how things work we like to feel in
control
at least i know i do
and um yeah i think that's important
so secondly we believe strongly in
privacy
we don't think that solutions that claim
ownership over organization's data is a
sustainable way going forward
and this is why most of our
sdks are extremely privacy focused we do
all of the evaluation of feature toggles
locally to avoid leaking data back to
our system so if you're using our paid
hosted version
none of the data actually leaves your
application it all stays in inside of
your ecosystem
and if you're using open source you
control the backend anyway so there's no
issue there
so with that said
i'm going to take you through the
architecture of unleash
and
we're going to go ahead and see how
unleash can help
before we get started setting up the
unleash open source let's go ahead and
take a brief look at the architecture
just we know what we are working with
and we'll start by taking a look at the
sdks
and sdk stands for software developer
kit
and what it basically is is pre-written
code in a programming language
that handles the connection to the
unleash api
so you will use the sdk in your own
application
and configure it to talk to the unleash
api and then the sdk will go ahead and
download the feature toggle
configuration at a given interval that
you can tune and it will store it
locally in memory
and that means that you don't have to do
an api call every time you want to check
if a feature toggle is on or off you're
basically doing the
evaluation
and the lookup
in the cache memory of your application
and that gives you a lot of performance
and it also means that none of your user
data is ever shared back with the
english server whether or not you're
using open source or
using the hosted solution
now let's talk about the api
so the unleash api is split into two
parts
you have the admin api which allows you
to do changes
to feature toggles add new ones and
update the future toggle configuration
and then you have the client api which
is one that serves the unleash sd
and this api is split from the admin api
because it's supposed to be really
stable
rarely changed
and you can create a specific api key
that's read-only so
that means that if you should lose your
api key for the
client api that serves the sdks
the attackers won't be able to use that
to actually make changes in the
configuration
so anything you can do in unleash you
can do via an api call so we have an
admin interface that we'll see later
but if you wanted to you could do
everything with curl commands or you
could wire up your ci pipeline to talk
to unleash
so let's talk about the proxy
remember earlier when we were talking
about the js bin integration and we said
that we might want to do this via a
proxy and one of the reasons for that is
the added security layer
so when you're talking to apis
you usually want to limit who has access
to the api and you do that by generating
a unique api key that will provide
access to the holder of this key
now when we're working in the front end
or the client side whether it be a web
application or an native app like an
android or ios application
you generally want to keep the secrets
out of this area because it's not a safe
space
so what the proxy provides is a layer
between your client-side application
and the unleashed server
that provides secure server-to-server
communication where you can safely store
your api key
in addition to the security of the api
key the unleash proxy will only return
evaluated toggles
and this is information that's already
available in your source code
which is free for everyone to look at if
they have access to the developer tools
and can inspect your code so
you are reducing the amount of
information that's traveling to your
front-end to
save information so to speak
aside from the added security you also
get improved performance by using the
proxy so the proxy can handle around 2
000 requests per second and it's really
easy to spin up and scale
new instances of the proxy because it's
just a stateless docker container
so
that's going to give you an easy way to
scale your
application by adding more proxies and
connecting them to the same unleash
application with that said let's go
ahead and set up a local instance of
unleash and a local proxy
and start exploring the possibilities of
using feature toggles
okay
so now we're going to go ahead and get
started setting up unleash open source
on our local machine
and in order to do that we are going to
use a software called docker
now docker is a way of
taking something called docker
containers
which are small virtual environments
that have all of the dependencies needed
to run a piece of software
and run that as a container on your
machine
so basically you're running a small
computer on your computer which has its
own operating system
and its own dependencies and it's
already bundled for you so that you
don't have to set up your machine to
replicate these dependencies
and it's a really powerful way to get
started just running software
if you want to
try out new software on your local
machine
so if you don't have docker make sure
you go to docker docker.io
and you hit the get started button up in
the right hand corner
and then just follow the instructions to
setup docker on your machine
and then you should have a
command called docker once you're done
that you can run in your terminal
so when you've done that
we are going to go ahead and open up the
unleash documentation
and
go to the deploy and manage tab
and
under option one we'll have the option
to use docker so there'll be some
commands here that we are going to use
we've modified them slightly for this
example because i've already set up some
of this on my machine and i want to do
it completely from scratch
so we are going to head over to our
terminal
and get started running these commands
in order to set up unleash
alright so here we are in the terminal
and the first thing we'll do is we'll go
ahead and create a network for docker
so we'll write docker network
create unleash net
and that's going to give us a hash
as a confirmation that we created the
network
and now we'll go ahead and set up
postgres
so we'll have this command right here
we'll say docker run
and we are providing some environment
variables
so obviously if you're running this in
production um you want to change the
password
and
make sure that you
choose something that's really secure
but for this example we are just gonna
go with the defaults here
and we'll start
the postgres on 5432 and we'll map it to
5001
on our local machine
so
if we start that
we should see the
postgres output
and right here we see that it's ready to
accept connections in the bottom
so now we can go ahead and
open up a new tab in our
terminal
and we will use a docker command to
start the unleash server
so we'll do docker run
and we'll map that to
4242 on our local machine
and we want to
make sure that we match the database
host
and the database port is going to be
5432
so
we hit enter on that
that's gonna start up the unleash
application
and now we can head over to our browser
and we can open a new tab here and visit
localhost 4242
and here we have the first screen that
you get to when you open up the address
in the browser
and as part of running the docker
container unleash will set up the
database and it will run some migration
and create all the tables and it will
also create a default user
so once you're here you can go ahead and
log in with the following credentials so
that's going to be admin as the username
and unleash for all as the password
go ahead and input that
and log in
and you're taken to the
main application interface now there's
not much here yet and we'll explore this
in a second but for now we want to
continue with the setup and we still
have to set up the proxy
and in order to do that we need to do a
few things in the ui here
so we'll go to the configure drop down
and we'll open up api access
so in here we can create and delete api
keys
and we also have the api url readily
available that we need to supply when we
are setting up the proxy
we'll go ahead and create our api token
now
and we'll hit this button in the right
hand corner
and that's going to trigger this dialog
and we're going to fill out the name
here and we'll call it proxy key
we're going to keep the token type to
client because that means that this key
will be read-only so it's only going to
be allowed to read data
we'll keep the project settings as it is
and then we'll change the environment to
development
and once we have that we can create the
token
and now we have everything we need to
set up the proxy
in order to do that we'll head back to
the documentation
and in the left hand side menu
we have under unleash sdks the unleash
proxy tab
if we open that up and scroll a little
bit down
then we can see instructions on how to
run the unleash proxy and
we are going to use this command right
here
but i have prepared it a little bit
let's go and head over to the terminal
and here we have the command that is
going to start the proxy
so what we've done here is we've
taken the api token that we just created
and the way we did that was we went to
the ui
and we hit copy on this to copy the
token to our clipboard
and then we
went back to the terminal and we put the
token in here
that's the api token that we created
now the unleash url points to the
local instance of unleash running on my
machine
and since i'm on mac i have to use host
docker internal for the proxy to access
this
port through the
virtual environment
if you're on mac
sorry linux or windows it's going to be
slightly different but i'm going to
include documentation on how to get that
done
so that you can follow along
in the top we have something called
unleash proxy secret
which is just a very thin layer of
security
um
like i said before anything that's
exposed on the client side is not really
a secret
so
the main
security of the proxy comes from the
fact that it takes the api key
and it hides it in server to server
communication and it doesn't
give any other data out other than
evaluated toggles and information that
already exists in your source code
so
while you will put up a secret here that
will
allow the clients that are connecting to
the proxy to
read from the proxy if they have this
secret the main security is within the
proxy itself
so with that said we can go ahead and
start it
and it's going to say that it's now
listening on port 3000
and if you want to go ahead and check if
this is working
we can take this curl command here
and copy that
and head back to the terminal
paste this in a
new terminal window and you can see that
we get response
with an empty toggles array which is
what we expect
okay so now that we have the proxy
running let's go ahead and take a quick
tour of the application and then we'll
create our first feature toggle
so we're currently in the main view we
want to navigate to the project section
and here we have the default project
which is the project that we get for
free when we start up
and this is the only project that we
have in the open source version but it
should be enough for our use case
if you open that up
we have a view that gives you a little
bit more information about the project
and we're not going to go through
everything but i want you to take note
of the environment section
if we head over here
you can see that we have the default
environment enabled and then we have
development and production as disabled
and this will be more important later
when we start to do more advanced
segmentation and we want to decide who
gets access to a feature
and we can segment that on environments
as well so
for now we're just going to turn this on
and we're going to head back to the
overview here
and we'll go ahead and we'll create our
first feature toggle
so in order to create a feature toggle
we just need to give it a unique name
and we'll go ahead and hit create
and then we are taken to the toggle
overview
now there's a lot of information here
but i want us to focus on this part in
the middle so see this traffic section
right here
notice how it corresponds to the
environments that we turned on in the
project
so since we turned on production and
development we now have the option to
see traffic from those environments
and if we scroll a little bit further
down
we have a strategy section
and this is an important concept in
unleash because strategies are really
rules that determine whether or not a
feature should be on or off
and you can add these rules to
any environment and they will only be
active in that environment
let's take a look at an example
so go to the strategies section
and
we want to navigate to the development
environment we don't want to add one to
the default environment and i'll explain
why in a second
but let's go ahead and add a gradual
rollout to the development environment
so what we see here is the configuration
of the strategy
and we can adjust this to be
25
and you can see that's reflected in the
execution plan here
and it says that 75 percent of your use
base is included
so if we save the strategy
now we can see that we have one strategy
in the development environment
but the environment is still disabled so
in order for this strategy to be
executed
we need to turn on the environment
and the difference between doing this
and what we just did in the project
settings is that
when we set it in the project we set a
project by setting for all of the
feature toggles that we create that
gives all feature toggles access to
these three environments
but what we're doing here is we're
saying
for this feature toggle we want the
strategies in this environment to
execute
so it's a handy way to turn on or off an
environment for a feature toggle
now what we can do is we can head over
to our terminal
and we can try the command again to call
against the proxy
and you can see that
we're getting the
pitch toggle in the first call
then we're getting in the empty array in
the second
and then we're getting the feature
toggle again in the
two subsequent calls
so what's going on
well if we take a look at the
configuration here we've set the
strategy execution to be 75
which means that
three out of four calls we should get
the feature toggle and that's exactly
what's happening so if we bump this up
to 100
and we hit save
and we head back to the terminal again
now if we go ahead and we
try to get the feature trouble
configuration
we should get it every time
all right so how does this work how does
the proxy know that we want to fetch the
configuration from the development
environment
well if you remember back to when we
initialized the proxy
remember the api token part here
well in here we have specified the
development environment as part of the
api token
and actually we configured that when we
created the token
so if we head back to the ui and we go
to the api access section
when you hit create api token you have
the
ability here to change the environment
so
that determines which environment it's
going to fetch the configuration for
alright so now we know enough to
implement this in a real application
all right so we're back to the component
that we started with and now we've taken
it out of the free code cam code base
and we moved it into a create react app
project just to reduce some of the
mental clutter and overhead when we're
working with this
and
we've done some modifications that will
use a feature toggle to turn on and off
and we'll go ahead and take a look at
that now
so
in the app.js file
you can see what's currently being
rendered to the screen
and inside of app we have a conditional
render component
and based on the condition that is given
it's either rendering the app.chatbot
component
or the app without chatbot component so
currently it's rendering this last
component here
and you can see these are defined in the
same file
so let's see what happens when we flip
this to true just to get the visual
confirmation here
and you can see now we have this chat
button in the bottom of the screen we
can click that
and we can type into the message box
here
and this is what we want to feature
toggle so
this is our feature and we want to turn
it on for a subset of our users
so
in order to do that
let's go to the
unleash
instance here
and we'll create a new feature toggle
we'll call that chatbot
and
we'll go to the strategies section
and we'll add a
strategy to the development
environment
so we'll set it to be a gradual rollout
of zero percent
begin with
and then we will
turn on the environment here
so from here we can go ahead and start
connecting our application to unleash
and we'll do that by
using the unleash proxy client
or react
so
we just need to follow the instructions
here and we'll start by adding the
unleash proxy client to our project
so open this up
and
add the proxy client
and then we can
prepare a little bit by taking this part
right here
and going back to our project and then
we can paste this in
and now we need to make sure that the
config here is correct so we'll swap
this out with
localhost
3000 and make sure we're on http
the proxy key is going to be
let's go ahead and check that
some secrets
so we'll put that in as well
we'll set the refresh interval to be
five seconds
and we'll change the app name to fcc
flagging
so the environment here is not related
to the strategies that we talked about
earlier this was actually in place
before we added strategy support so the
only thing that affects where you are
fetching or which configuration you are
fetching
is the api key
and the configuration of that api key
okay
so with that said we now have a config
that we are supplying to this flag
provider
and we should be able to head into our
app component and start using our
feature flags
so in here we're going to grab a few
things from the proxy clients
so i'll import the use flag and use flag
status
and
what we can do now is we can say enabled
equals use flag and then we need to pass
the
feature toggle name here so let's go
ahead and make sure that
this is the actual name of the feature
toggle
and we can see that here
that should be fine
if we now head back we can go ahead and
say
use flag status
and we want to grab
flags ready
from this object
so if not blank's ready
we are going to return
a
loader
just a simple loader for now
otherwise we'll use the enabled flag to
render the correct version
log this out as well after the flags
ready just to make sure we are
triggering that
event
if we go back to the browser
and now we can open up our application
and if we refresh here we expect to see
the loading flash and we expect to see
the boolean logged out in the console
and we do
so
the
sdk has successfully been wired up
and it's set up a
polling in the background so
if we go to unleash now
and we change this gradual rollout to be
a hundred percent
that should
be reflected when we go back here
we should be able to see that the
new component
is being loaded because this has been
flipped to true so now the conditional
render is loading the
right component so if we hit here
we open the chat bot and we can interact
with it
and we can also go back to unleash
and turn this off again
and that should propagate and remove the
chatbot
nice
so i never get tired of seeing that even
though this is just localhost
when you're doing this in production it
just feels like magic
and
now we've seen how it behaves when you
have it at zero percent and when you
have that hundred percent which is what
we expect it's either 100 on or 100 off
but let's try changing the gradual
rollout to
50 for example
and we'll hit save
and let's go ahead and refresh this page
and we'll refresh just a couple of times
here
because we would expect the chatbot to
turn up 50 of the time right because
that's what we set the gradual rollout
to
but it seems like it doesn't so there's
something going on here
let's copy this url
and we'll open up a new incognito window
and we didn't get it there
let's try this again
and not there either
so maybe third time's charm
and not there either
so that's interesting because it is a 50
chance
and there we have it
so here it turns up
and
the reason
that it turns up here and if we refresh
this
it's going to stay here
because
we
are using the session id
to ensure that we get the same
experience so if we take a look at this
call here
you can see that the session id is sent
as a parameter to the proxy and as long
as you stay within the same session
you'll get the same experience
because we don't want this to change
just
randomly right we want the users to have
the same experience even if they reload
the page
in the same session
that's why in our other tab
we don't get the chatbot because we
already received
a version of the site that does not have
the chatbot turned on
and
even though
the percentage is set to 50 we are now
in the category that will not receive
the feature
and this is quite useful because we want
to be able to keep a consistency in the
way that the user experiences the site
now
session id and that's quite limiting
because the user might turn off their
computer they might go on their phone
they might visit a friend's house and
use their computer and then the session
id can't be used in order to determine
whether or not the user should get the
same version because the session id will
be different from time to time
and maybe there's a way we can look at
where we can actually keep it consistent
even if the user changes their device
and to do that we need to take a look at
the unleashed context
so the unleash context is used for a
couple of things it's used for strategy
standardization
it's used for stickiness
and it's also used to pass properties to
custom strategies if you implement those
so
there's a few fields here like dynamic
context fields that you can populate
and one is the user id
another is the session id
and then we have the remote address
and finally we have the properties
which is a map
that you can where you can put anything
you want
now
remember back to when we talked about
the architecture
we said that when the sdk does the
evaluation
it receives the configuration from the
unleashed server
and then it takes the context that it
receives
and it merges the two together and makes
a decision on whether or not this is on
or off
so
to illustrate that
we're going to take a look at the code
here
and this is the nodejs sdk which is
basically what the proxy builds upon
it wraps around this sdk
and this here is the is enabled call for
a feature toggle
so you receive the feature toggle name
and you can see we received the context
as well
and what is happening here is we're
taking the feature from the internal
repository of the sdk so that means that
the sdk has already
fetched the configuration
from the unleash server
and it will use that configuration
together with the context and make a
decision on whether or not this feature
is enabled
and this is also why we recommend
self-hosting the proxy because the
user data or context that you send from
the client application that's going to
be used
as we just discussed to evaluate the
toggle in the proxy and that's where the
data flow stops so the user data does
not go to the unleash api
so if you self-host a proxy you have 100
control over your data
all right so now we've seen a little bit
about the unleashed context
let's go ahead and implement this and
see if we can use that to get a
consistent experience for our users
so
we'll open up the
unleash proxy client documentation
and we'll scroll to the bottom
and check the documentation here for the
context
and it looks like we can
take the use unleash context hook
and get a function here
so that's what we're going to do
if we open up our
code we can add the
use unleash context here
and we'll say update context equals use
unleash context
and then we are going to add a use
effect here
so we'll add that to the import
up top
and we'll say use effect
and we only want this to happen on mount
and then we want to update the context
with a user id
and let's call this user one for now
and this should be enough for us to be
able to provide a
steady experience for the user
regardless of the device
because
if we head back to the unleash instance
and check out the gradual rollout
strategy here
you can see that we have the stickiness
set to default
and the default actually checks for a
user id in the context first
then a session id and if it can't find
either of those it's going to be random
and you can explicitly choose user id or
session id here but the default is going
to look for first the user id and then
the session id
so this should be enough for us
to get a sticky experience let's check
it out
if we go to our application
and we open up the developer tools
and we can now see that the calls that
are being sent to the proxy include the
user id here
this means that no matter how many
windows
we open up
we should get the same experience
remember
when we did this before
it was a 50 chance that we would get
another
experience
but now you can see that
the experience is the same no matter how
many times i will open this
new window
let's try one more time
just to make sure we are completely sane
and we can see that we still have the
same result
now let's jump back to the code
and notice that the value user1 here is
hard coded
now
this doesn't really make sense because
that means that every single user that
visits your site will use this value to
hash and get the same result every time
what you typically want to do is you
want to get this value from an api
and that's going to be a unique
identifier for each user
and this will ensure that every user
gets a different result
all right so we're taking a look at the
gradual rollout strategy and we've also
been through the unleashed context
and now we can also take a look at some
of the other strategies that we have
available to us
so before we start let's go ahead and
put the gradual rollout to zero
and
we can go ahead and add a user id
strategy
now a user id strategy is typically a
strategy you want to use while you're
developing something because it will
allow you to pass a set of user ids that
will get access to the feature so you
could have this behind a feature flag in
production
and you could give access to a specific
set of users which could be the
developers or maybe a product manager or
a tester
or another stakeholder in the
organization
so
if we put in user one here
and we add this
now we'll see that the execution plan is
updated so zero percent of the user base
is included
and will give access to one user
so if we go back to
the
application
now we can see that we have access to
the feature here
so we can go ahead and open up the
chatbot again
and
now we can do exactly the same as we did
with the gradual rollout we can go ahead
and either remove this strategy entirely
or we could just remove the user
and if we now head back to the
application
now we don't have access to the feature
anymore so
that's completely based on
the values that are sent into the
context that we just discussed
so since i have user one
as a value here
i will get access to this feature if my
user id
is defined in the strategy
so
if i go ahead and go back to the
strategy here and put user 2
that's not going to work because my user
id is user1
so if we go back to the application
we can see that we don't have access
here
but if we go back to the strategy again
and add our user id
and hit save
we should be able to see that the
feature now shows up again and we can
once again open up and interact with the
chatbot
right
so now that you've seen how to use the
user id strategy to give access to
certain users
let's jump back to the
unleash instance
and we'll have a look at the strategies
section here
because what's really cool is that you
can have as many strategies as you want
and as long as the environment is on
they will all be evaluated
and if any one of them return true for
the given context then the feature will
be on for that user
so that means that if you have a gradual
rollout set to zero like we have here
then it will be on or no users
but we will also go ahead and check the
user id strategy
and since my user id is user 1 and i
pass that in
i still get access to the feature so
every strategy is evaluated
and that makes it really flexible
because you can add as many strategies
as you want that constrain on different
properties
and you can even create your own custom
strategies and provide the
implementation in code
so that you can create strategies that
don't really exist in the system out of
the box but that you need in the context
that you're operating in
so if we open up the sidebar here we can
take a look at the built-in strategies
and we've already been through two of
them
and the ip and host strategy work very
similarly to the user id strategy
so if we add the ip strategy
we need to provide an ip here
and once we've added that and we saved
the strategy
we can see that the execution plan is
updated
but now we need to take this ip and we
need to add it to our
code so let's go ahead and remove our
user id because
we want to see that we don't have access
to the feature anymore
if we jump back to our application
now we don't have access to the chatbot
but if we go ahead and take this ip
address
and we head back to the code
now we can add a remote address property
here
and we put in the ip address
and let's go back to the browser
and now we once again have access via
the remote address strategy so all of
the strategies have been evaluated
and this final one returned true
so we get access to the feature because
our ip address matches the value that is
put in here
all right so now we've gotten our feed a
little bit bet with feature toggles and
we've seen how we can use strategies to
target different segments of the user
base
so what i want to focus on next is
experimentation
and sometimes as developers we want to
develop different versions of a feature
and try it out so we can determine which
one performs better
and
that's a process that keeps the users
close to us
and that's important because we don't
want to just take a feature and run with
it and develop something that we think
is right we want to continuously
validate that we're actually building
something
that gives real value to our users
and in order to do that experimentation
and a b testing can be quite powerful
tools that we can use to figure out
which one performs better
and i'm going to show you how to do this
in unleash
but before i do i just want to mention
quickly how we think about working with
other services because we don't have any
built-in analytics in unleash and one of
the reasons for that is actually back to
our philosophy
because we believe that
there's a lot of software being written
today and there's a lot of great work
that others do
and
for example analytics you have great
providers that provide a world-class
analytics experience
and we believe that it's our job to
make as many integration points
and provide as flexible as system as
possible so that you can use the great
work of others
and combine services to gain a better
experience
so
we're not really focusing on
implementing analytics in the
traditional sense when it comes to
experimentation
we instead focus on
giving you the option of taking some
provider that you're probably already
using today
and pairing that with data from unleash
and then you can send that off to your
analytics provider and do the
uh necessary
analysis on the data
so with that said let's jump into it and
see how we can do some a b testing with
unleash
okay so here we are back in the unleash
application and we've done a little bit
of cleanup on the chatbot page toggle
as you can see we removed some of these
strategies that were here before and
what we're left with is the gradual
rollout that's rolling out to 100
percent of our users
so
we're going to use this feature toggle
and set up an a b experiment
and in order to do that we'll need to
learn about a new concept in unleash
called variance
so we'll navigate to the variance tab
and we'll go ahead and add a couple
we'll have variant a here
and then we'll add another one
and now we basically have the setup that
we need
we still need to do some work on the
cold side of things but
before we do let's try and understand
the weight distribution here
so you can see that each variant has a
weight distribution of 50 percent
and this means that
50 of the users that are visiting our
site and that get access to this feature
will get variant a
and 50 will get variant b
so let's take a very concrete example
and say we have a hundred users visiting
we have a gradual rollout that says that
everyone visiting will get access
that means that 50 users will get
variant a
and 50 users will get variant b
but let's change the strategy just to
see how that affects the
weight distribution
so we'll change this now to 50
and we'll head back to the variance
let's take the same example again we
have a hundred users visiting our site
we only have 50 percent rollout so that
means that we only have 50 users that
get access to the chatbot feature
and since we have a 50 50 weight
distribution that means that of those 50
users
25 users will get variant a and 25 users
will get variant b
so it's all relative to the amount of
people that get access to the feature
toggle
so you can think of strategies sort of
like a gatekeeper that lets people
through or not and then the variants can
be thought of as pathways that we send
the people that get through the gates on
after they are let through
so currently we have variant a and
variant b which means that there are two
possible pathways for the people that
are lit true
and we could easily add more pathways if
we wanted to
but hopefully that makes sense
and we'll now go ahead and implement the
code side of this
so before we jump to the code let's head
back to the strategies
and we'll make sure that we set the
gradual rollout back to 100
and with that we can check that we
propagate this to the application
and we do so let's head into the code
now
and we'll grab the use variant hook
from the unleash proxy client library
and then we'll do variant
equals use variant
and we'll
put in the feature toggle name
so with that
we can go ahead and log this out here
we'll open up the console
and we can see here that
we got the variant a which corresponds
to with the variant name that we added
or one of the variants
you see
here
we have the variant a here so we
automatically got one of the variants
that we defined
now
we also have the enable true here which
means that we don't really need to use
the use flag hook anymore because we get
both of the data properties
in this object so
we'll go back to the code
and we'll remove the enabled
and then we'll say
variant enabled here
and we'll pass the variant as a prop
here to this app with chatbot component
and let's accept it here
what we want to do now based on this
variant
we are going to render a different
welcome message in the chatbot
so in order to do that
let's create a new function
inside of the
configuration here
and we will create
a
getconfig method
which is going to take a welcome message
and it's going to return
the configuration that we put in here
but the initial message is going to be
the
welcome message
so we'll export
the config function
and then we'll head back to app.js
and we will
rename this
okay so let's remove the use flag here
since we're not using that anymore
and we'll scroll down to our
app with chatbot component where we are
accepting the variant as a parameter
now we're gonna do
config equals
config
and then we want to paste in the message
here and i've already prepared that so
we skip some typing
but what we want to do is we want to
check the variant name
like we're doing here
and if the variant name is variant a
then we
want to have this welcoming message
otherwise
we want to have this welcoming message
so we'll hit save
and we'll pass this into
our get config
and we are passing the config here so
everything is as it should be
with that we can go ahead and open up
the browser again
and you can see that we get the
welcome message here
if we refresh
and we open up the chatbot again
here we have the same message so that's
working fine
so
let's see if we can trigger
this message here as well because
right now we have been given a variant
and that variant is not going to change
because we
have passed in the user id here
and that will ensure that the variant is
sticky as well so we'll get the same
experience
whenever we open the website
but what we could do in order to
trigger or force
a change is we can take this user id
here
and we can go back to our
unleash
application
and inside of variant b
we can go ahead and add an overwrite
and you see here we have a context field
called user id
let's put our user in there
and we'll hit save
and you can see now we have an override
on this variant
so if we go back to our application now
and we refresh
now we can see that we have another
message and that's in fact the message
that we
provided as an alternative
so here we're using variants to change
the messaging in the chatbot when we
launch it
but that's a simple example and if we
take a look at the code all we're really
doing is we're checking the variant name
and then
doing something based on that so here
we're changing the text but it could
easily be
rendering a different component
or
changing something within another
component it's really up to you and what
your experiment entails and how you want
to go about it but it's as flexible as
it needs to be to
cover the use cases that you could have
and here we only have two variants but
you could easily have three or four or
five
and
that's up to you and your your ex
now let's talk about analytics
i mentioned briefly before that we
prefer to defer to world-class analytics
providers
in order to allow you to integrate with
providers that you most likely are
already using today
i wanted to show you how you can use
unleash
together with your analytics provider
and create a trail that makes it so that
you can track
a given variant through your application
so i'm going to show an example with
google analytics
and i've already installed the
react google analytics package here so
let's go ahead and
initialize it
and then we'll take a look at how we
could do this
so what we'll do is we'll import
react ga
from
react
ea
and then we'll go ahead and initialize
it so
inside of our application we can put it
in a use effect
we initialize it with the
following
parameters and then this would be your
unique google account key
all right so let's do a few more changes
first of all we'll create a variable for
our user id
and we'll put the user id in here
and then
we will
place that in here
and we'll replace the value here as well
and then what we'll do
is we'll go down to our app with chatbot
and we'll go ahead and add a user
picture as well
and we'll make it dependent on the
variant
and we'll save variant
name
and variant enabled
let's do react
ea
and we'll use an event here
and then we can send an event to
google analytics
so we can say label
application loaded
and
let's go ahead and add the variant
that's going to be the variant name
and then we'll give it an action
it's a required property
we'll say
application loaded with
and give it the variant
name
and we'll also want to give the user id
here
that means we need to go up in our
parent component
we need to pass in the user id
here
and we'll accept that as a parameter
and now we have the ability to send an
event
to google analytics
and that event
includes the user id and the variant
name
and that means that now you have your
baseline because you have the user id
and you know which variant that user id
loaded up with
so if you're tracking
more actions on your site
for example if you want the user to
convert or in this case let's say we
wanted to check whether or not the user
is interacting with the chatbot based on
the message
we could go ahead and add more events
with the user id and the variant name in
other places of the application where it
makes sense
and we know that
the action has been taken by the user
with this variant okay so that's the way
we can track the user across the
application
if that's what you want to do
all right so i want to show you a little
bit about the metrics as well because
one of the coolest things about feature
toggles is that you can see
the updates live and you can see who is
getting access to what feature or how
many people are getting access to a
feature
so when you wire up the sdks and you put
up the api key
you'll start sending metrics based on
the environment that that api key is
configured for so i currently have a
script running that's calling against
the api with an api key that's enabled
for development
and we currently have the
strategies set to a hundred percent so
we have the gradual rollout
set to 100 so everyone who
is asking against this api
is getting
enabled back for this feature
so let's go ahead and update this
we'll set the gradual rollout to 50
percent
and
we head back to our application now
we're going to be able to see as this
updates that more and more people are
getting denied
the access to the feature and it's going
to creep back
towards the 50
mark over time
and that's how you can be sure that when
you're setting a gradual rollout
or you're setting a strategy
configuration
that you expect is going to
be enabled for
a subset of your users you could use the
metrics to verify that that is in fact
happening
and now we can see that we're slowly
making our way towards the 50 mark in
more and more of the users that are
asking for access towards the api are
getting denied
which is what we expect
right so we talked about metrics a
little bit and besides that there are
some other methods for monitoring that
you can do in unleash
and if you remember we talked to ebar
earlier about technical depth and we
take it really seriously because you
have to be able to clean up your code
and remove feature flags as you go along
to have a sustainable workflow when
you're working with feature toggles
so
i'm here in the demo instance because it
has a lot more
feature flags available and i want to
show you the
health dashboard that we built
which is sort of a work in progress but
we have an early version of it ready
and we can head over to the project
and this is a demo instance that anyone
can log in and use so there will be a
lot of
projects here and a lot of data
because it's kind of a sandbox that
anyone can use and try out unleash
so
if we head over to the health section
here you see we have a health rating and
we have a toggle report
and then we have all of the feature
totals in this project down in the
overview here
and
you get some information here
basically the name of the toggle when it
was last seen which is when did we last
register and sdk
asking for this feature toggle
and so it's if it's never seen then
you've never connected up an sdk and
started to use this feature toggle but
if you do have a value here then you
know that it's eight days since this
last was in use which might indicate
that it was used in a
local environment and not in the
production environment because if you're
in production you would expect it to be
continuously
asked for
and then you have like you can see some
more information when it's created
and there is an expired column which
basically
based on the
type of feature toggle you create we use
some internal data
to calculate when it's expired and for
release toggle that's about 40 days
because
that's what the research indicates that
should be the lifetime or life
expectancy of a toggle like that
so you can use this dashboard to get an
overview over
toggles that might be
ripe for cleaning up and it can help you
in the effort to
clean up your toggles and
get rid of some of the technical depth
all right
that's it for the course
and i want to thank you so much for
tuning in and giving me the opportunity
to explain this concept
and i hope it's been a valuable lesson
in terms of understanding how to work
with feature toggles and how you can use
them to simplify your workflow
and run experiments within your code
now if you're wondering where you can
find unleash we're on social media
obviously but the most important part is
the code that's on github
we are after all an open source
organization
and you can go to
the unleash repositories and you can
browse through all of the code
and if you want to contribute there are
opportunities for that as well if you
have any other questions you can tune in
to our open slack channel we'll be happy
to help you along if you want to get
started using feature toggles
now if you want to know where you can
reach me i'm on twitter under at f
osberg
or you can find me at my youtube channel
which is called frederick osborne coding
lessons here on youtube
and with that i hope you have a really
great day